tomorrow on CBS MacGyver is back Lucas
till has become our new primetime crush
I mean check him out right with or
without that trademark eighties hair I
love Richard Dean Anderson Sam mullet I
think I had a mullet when I was a kid
I've got a picture somewhere and someone
has already put on Twitter they've like
photocopied his mullet on to me sure
Lucas has wrapped the same 80s mullet
and he gave this settled missile on the
shoulder nod to the original but this
shower scene remains our favorite of the
26 year old you want to call me a sex
symbol that's up to you man
or someone else I'm definitely can't
admit to that myself oh yeah I'm single
man I'm singing that's Mickey carpenter
no one's better on a keyboard Lucas
maybe all James Bond sexy and smart as
the new MacGyver but when we visited the
set we found Hollywood's newest romance
is bill enough between Lucas and George
EADS quite frankly we'd been at dinner
and he said he was he was glad to
finally meet somebody that as fast crazy
as he was my man saving the world in
style George he looks after me and make
sure I don't die he uses the guns cuz
MacGyver famously doesn't use John loves
you baby
I totally might go I hope we keep
getting along I can you imagine cut to
us three years from now shaking each
other's necks we're ready for you oh
let's go
and as for those action scenes Lucas has
this look-alike stunt guy but he
actually likes to take on a lot of the
danger himself why would I do something
like that to save the day because I'm a
guy